donc là on est décomposé la lumière
blanche et on voit toutes les couleurs
des ateliers pour apprendre à aimer les
sciences proposés aux élèves du lycée de
la pleain de naufle attrape par des
étudiants l'établissement adhère depuis
2010 au dispositifs des cordés de la
réussite Dariane a 14 ans elle est
volontaire depuis un an on va visiter
différentes choses les découvertes ou
les musées et on fait des visites une
cordée en terme de montagne c'est le
lien qui unit les alpinistes les cordées
de la réussite en terme scolaire c'est
la même chose des établissements
d'enseignement supérieur nous des
partenariats avec des collèges et lycées
issus de zones d'éducation prioritaire
l'intérêt de décorderé de la réussite
c'est aussi d'avoir des jeunes qui
transmettent c'est-à-dire que les jeunes
qui sont en cordé ont des tuteurs qui
sont des étudiants des têtes de cordé
donc nous avons dans le département 78
comme tête de cordé l'université de
Saint-Quentin nous avons un chaussée
nous avons un gros Paritech et nous nous
avons TR is le tutora marche vraiment
bien on le sait autant d'ailleurs dans
cette expérience là que dans la vie
normale d'un établissement ou bien
souvent un aîné aide un plus jeune ici à
trrape 40 élèves en bénéficie et comme
parins l'établissement compte par
exemple le prestigieux lycée parisien
jansçon de sailli la caractéristique des
élèves de la ville de trappe c'est que
ils ont tendance à être un peu résignés
par rapport à leur parcours et d'où
l'intérêt décorder de la réussite où
justement on doit donner de l'ambition à
nos élèves c'est vraiment une une une
aventure humaine très enrichissante hein
que ce soit de la part des étudiants qui
viennent chez nous de nos élèves aussi
hein et et et même pour les adultes donc
les différents acteurs c'est des moments
privilégiés d'échang que nous n'aurions
très certainement pas l'occasion d'avoir
en dehors descorder de la réussite
l'intérêt c'est donc la transmission
entre jeunes de témoignages et de pour
entraîner l'émulation dans le
département une cinquantaine de lycées
et une vingtaine de collèges participent
à ces
cordé